er muss dafür aber die druckplatte liegt
da noch freuen und herzlich willkommen
zu einer weiteren folge vom mega projekt
und zwar nämlich gerade bei gewitter auf
sieht man zwar nicht so schlecht weil
ich den regen ausgestellt habe aber man
hört ab und zu ein paar blitze und
zusammen durch den regen stapfe ich hier
mit elf mit kate hall aloha wir haben
uns gedacht dass ihr zusammen aufnehmen
weil cap ist eine person die auch mir
ein wenig das beibringen wollte mit
bienenzucht nicht so aber eher so
generator energie machen weil ich habe
ja gesagt jetzt werde ich im titellied
beschäftigen hat mir hier letzten chance
im generator zusammengebastelt und
wollte mich jetzt einen mails raider
erstmal setzen ganz wichtig ich habe
jetzt bei mir noch mal kurz damit
zwischen auf wissen ich habe mich jetzt
mal schlau gemacht was zauberkraft
angeht komplett also ja zaubern das
heißt ich werde jetzt nebenbei
bienenstöcke machen und sauber fest ich
werde mich potter dem was ich denke ich
erst mal an werde ist dass ich mir
jemand sagen was an pflanzen werde und
zwar so einfällt wir haben zwar die
möglichkeit immer weiß parkers bauen
allerdings irgendwie auch besser wenn
man sich dann selber wieder eingestellt
und dafür brauche ich erstmal erhalten
man wollte ja auch nicht so viel eifer
verbrennen weil
es gibt die möglichkeit dass wir mit wie
heißt das hier links pumps der major
genau dass man damit auf jeden fall mehr
doppelt so viel durch sogar aus kriegen
kann
so ist es deswegen werde ich jetzt immer
nur das wenigste verbracht ihr seht
schon hier ich habe noch eine menge
ärzte die noch total unangetastet sind
wie sowie der pflasterstein untersuche
ich ja ganz einfach hinkommen
also ich wollte mir jetzt erstmal
allerdings machen also ich weiß nicht ob
das mitgekriegt hass der tim ist jetzt
auch mit dabei minecraft expert.de genau
muss ich genau der ist jetzt ein nachbar
hier also wenn in seinem grundstück wo
bist du der luft ich fliege geb potter
da sind parteilos data ist das unter dem
motto ich hab nämlich mops bonner
gefallen und da wollte ich mir was macht
das wollte ich auch noch fragen teilt
ihre ich habe davor eine ca 170 blöcke
von hot spot unter der erde und ich weiß
nicht ob ich mir dann eine falle bauen
darf wenn ich die mit meinem grundstück
hier verbinde oder ob das jetzt also es
ist ja sowieso in der mitte gab
spekuliert oder es wird verlangt dass
irgendwer bürgermeister wird und ich sag
nur laut kfv präsident
ich werde definitiv ausscheidet
bürgermeister weil weil sie nicht habe
ich richtig spielen und ich berichten
ich sag mal so ich gedichte ich weiß gar
nicht wie so mich die leute fragen ich
finde das ganz nett ich mache ich
beschäftige mich gerne damit diese
kleine kiste ja nicht oft geschlagen
ich bin eigentlich wenden wenn einer
bürgermeister werden könnte dann muss es
auf jeden fall eine person sein die oft
hier drauf spielt und die gerichte
urteilen kann und ich glaube das wären
dienstag eigentlich so am besten dafür
geeignet also seine stimme habe ich
schon erkauft wird dann auch für die
stimme film wieder aufrichten
dies in anderen in ordnung eine
vernünftige person und nicht so jemanden
wie den nahrung gespielt und mich oder
ich sag mal so ich kann das jetzt sein
soll ach so genau ich brauche hier ein
bisschen papier
ich wollte mit zaubern anfang und ich
habe jetzt hier bist meine drohen ich
versuche ein paar waldige drohnen oder
weil die königin zu bekommen ich habe
jetzt erst mal auf die gemeinde und die
in ihr dgn de was ist das für ein
charakter habe denn was ist eine melone
was ist also hilfe rücke eigentlich
droge es regnet deswegen können die
mitarbeiter aus sich legen ob die fei
nicht immer schön hell hier
das habe ich jetzt auch mal gewehrt
jetzt hier definitiv das musizieren im
wasser machen überall damit ich hier
immer so ein bisschen allerdings inhalt
kann weil es so ja genau ich weiß nicht
was ich machen sollte wollte ich brauche
einfach nur papier
das habe ich nicht und die biene machen
jede arbeit ich wollte auch mein
grundstück irgendwie auch von aber ich
habe null ahnung wie ich das machen will
ich habe wirklich keinen blassen
schimmer wie ich meine baseball kappe
ich werde das ganze erstmal nur noch 15
machen also so die ganzen zunft mäßigen
sachen ihr seht schon meine kühe sind in
so einem kleinen loch das ist total
freundlich gegenüber den mehr als ich
werde das in zukunft auf jeden fall
besser machen weil das jetzt erstmal
alles nur so ist damit ich hier so ein
bisschen was aufbauen kann aber bei dir
finde ich das calwer jetzt schon eine
ebenmaß guckt immer mein grundstück an
die hälfte da ist das ist bei sehr
vielen so dass sie also die sache war
mein grundstück westlich hat es von
anfang an gesehen dass ja es war ja so
leuchtet es war da waren überall höhlen
daran über löcher tja ich habe die
ganzen höhlen einfach ich hab die höhlen
wirklich zu gebaut weil ich hatte
einfach keinen bock dass ich hier dann
offenberg wohl irgendwie wie das
beispiel ist das was du kennst du mein
mining lasershow ja hast mir schon
erzählt aber kann sich noch zeigen
übrigens meine sachen bleibt übrigens
erst mal wieder am start die ganzen
leute haben mir viele tipps in die
kommentare geschrieben und auch per
email und das finde ich ja ganz gut
wirklich eine e mail schreibt ja also
ein relativ viele tipps das war auf
jeden fall sehr sehr geil und zwar
wollte ich gleich mal ganz kurz was
vorlesen was mir einer geschrieben hat
also hab ich mir ein paar stichpunkte
ausgemacht das wirst du wahrscheinlich
schon kennen kev aber ich weiß dass noch
nicht wusste dass man nicht bzw
deswegen wollte ich das gleich einfach
mal ganz gut vor dir ich hoffe du
erlaubst mit hat ja klar dann schießt
auch ich bin gespannt ich dachte du
sollst nämlich irgendwas noch stark
du kannst im nebenbei wo du vorliest
kannst du zu mir kommt dann zeige ich
ihnen meine leser richtig glatt ein
halbes grundstück und eine gute ich
suche das mal ganz kurz ich hab mir das
ist wirklich fantastisch zum eben
ausgleichen man sieht das schon jeder
klick irgendwie einfach in der vierten
linie also mining drill kennst du dass
das wahrscheinlich hat ja das kann man
so wie wir hier hat genug das thema
energie aufbereiten muss also mit
füttern muss aber das gibt es für alles
es gibt jedes werkzeug im energy form
das heißt dass du bist nur einmal kraft
muskel und energie optics also im weißt
du genau den vorteil von meiningen will
weil ich glaube ja der vorteil von
einigen will ist ja eigentlich dass man
dadurch stellen abbauen kann oder dass
allein das ist nicht das habe ich auch
gedacht mein rad einfach nur die den
vorteil dass es so wie es nie gegeben
ja man spitzhacke die aber niemals
kaputten entweder die energie dann
längst wieder auch zur herstellung musst
du musst immer aufpassen dass du damit
energie arbeitet kohle rein tolle da ist
das nun endlich energie
ja nee du musst in der energiequelle
irgendwie will die zu hause haben und
dann einfach zum beispiel wenn ein
generator hast oder eine black box wo
sich aus speichert dann dort eben
netbooks allerdings etwas an die leute
die an der technischen features
informiert ist der kann die energie vom
generator speichern immer richtig also
von allen sachen und danach gibt der
zehnmal so gespeicherten mfs wer nochmal
besser ist aber redbox das grundlegende
der ok gut also dann habe ich mir noch
ausgeschrieben also dass die sachen
nicht mehr machen möchte jetpack wollte
ich auch machen verlangt nicht allzu
viele ressourcen oder sonst wirklich
einfach also ich hab noch mal angeschaut
und es geht wirklich verdammt schnell
also wenn du schon die basics hass und
die ressourcen da ist das ein klacks
ja gut also ein jetpack beispiel machen
da gibt's dann allerdings auch wieder
verschiedene jetpacks gibt einmal ein
unendliches jetpacks ist jetzt mein job
hast mittel genommen wird befeuert wird
das kannst du nicht wollen weil wir
nicht genug öl haben auch in der region
nicht da wollte ich auch noch was machen
aber das ging leider nicht
und wenn du in der liste schaus von den
kräften rezepten hast du einmal das mit
voller energie und einmal das mit ohne
energie muss das electric jetpack ohne
energie kräften und das ist das gleiche
unendliche haltbarkeit und mit energie
gespeist also halten genau und wenn du
halt eben zwei schlauen solar heim dazu
kräftig jetzt habt dann legt sich das
jetpack einer rede am tag drauf ok dann
habe ich hier noch kettensäge stehen und
zwar ist das zum bäume fällen viel
besser geeignet weiß ich allerdings
nicht ob wir das machen soll oder nicht
weil das ist sehr gut also ist genau das
gleiche wie gesagt die werkzeugen wieder
mining tool halt nur für die achse zu
sagen ja okay dann habe ich hier meister
der zerkleinert die ärzte zu cooler also
den wollt ich mir auf jeden fall jetzt
erstmal brown habe ich schon das
crafting rezept das ist das wichtigste
dafür brauche ich einen blog für den
brauch nicht etwa feinde macht jetzt
erstmal den schienen blockiert jetzt
noch schnell die laser allein zugleich
habe ich mein ganzes grundstück zerlegt
ach so ja warte ich komme es ist immer
wie viel ich muss mal sehen was wird was
ihr gab er noch ein berg gesehen da ist
jetzt ja weg haben wir drei feuerstellen
broich auch noch das heißt die oriental
den ich immer bei ja ich bin auf
entwickeln guttenberg war ist schon weg
okay ich bin auch weg zu dir was du dass
dafür eine kiste für die du da hast das
ist eine im kiste im versuch darauf
zuzugreifen eigentlich solltest du es
nicht können weil die sind von mathe
geschützt doch kann ich ja das kann ich
meine bienen im lager er drohte gar
gemeine drohne baldige drohne habe schon
bisschen sortiert ich habe die zahl der
typische und morastigen und die machen
gibt und die vergibt noch nicht niemals
seite sind stecke ich dich im himmel
seite also schau mal hier die linie die
jetzt wegschmelzen 1 1 click halter okay
das ist leicht es ist mega chillig was
ist nämlich dazwischen stelle also du
fängst ihr feuer und brennt das kloster
eingesammelt ich hab schon 23 kisten
erde ich habe mein ganzes unter das
grundstück von mining drittels ausfüllen
lassen bis zum grundstein der verlangt
aber relativ viele ressourcen nur einen
tipp also dieses ding
das ist schon etwas aufwendiger arbeit
also das heizen und glänzen die ganzen
maschinenkosten halt mehr so was mich
ein bisschen auf recap dass das dürfen
wir nicht beheben dass sie diese ganzen
schlaglöcher sind im boden wieder
normalen weil man ja inzwischen in von
beiden grundstücken dieses ganze hier
dürften wir das hier guck dir das sie
zum beispiel mal ein drehbuch das ist
mein was passiert die ganze du hast die
eagles viel wasser na ja das habe ich
alles daraus geschöpft
ja gut würdest du mir erlauben dass ich
das zu bauen darf alles vergleich dann
erde von dir bekommen so viel ist klar
welche den gut wie willst du hier erst
mal 56 also aber dieser mine laser ist
wirklich von der energie herr verdammt
teuer und braucht er denn dann energie
200.000 redbox fast 40.000
und jeder schuss fürst 1000 aber ich
verstehe es gerade in bedburg speichert
energie wie sie braucht wieder energie
der nähe die blackbox speichert energie
aber der meinung laser braucht energie
seit der kapazität von 200.000 und durst
tust sein ich habe übrigens wie man ganz
cool spenden weil es das gedacht
empfänger kommt bei mir dann gehst dann
kannst du das sogar ziemlich dass meine
da muss ich dir das nicht erklären
meine türe abgeordneten die parteien
laut müsste wahrscheinlich wirklich
besser weil regen hier für dich gleich
welches in den usa muss dafür aber die
druckplatte liegt da noch also wenn du
hier rein schaust ich hab über glasfaser
und zu verwalten
aber hier wenn hier rein gehst das ist
das war besser die linke speichert
600.000 klickt man darauf an sich die
jugend der meilen leser der legt sich
auf der fließt natürlich die energie
hier voraus das ist ein nfc schon dass
er schon die weitere formen genau und
dann gibt's noch mfs der speicher
zehn-millionen-stadt 600.000 und was
soll das hier werden beim hilton g20
habe glasfaserkabel das ist jetzt im
einmal damit löcher in chamdo tar das
ist das was ein dreier unterschied
zwischen glasfaser zum beispiel koffer
cable kupferkabel nach vier reichweite
verliert ist energie oder spannung
revier immer bei und es kann nur 32
minecraft tools transportieren
gold kann 124 128 transportieren und
verliert aber noch schneller energie und
dann gibt es doch dieses insane
das kann 512 schicken aber verliert nach
einem blog show und glasfaserkabel kann
auch das müsste glaube ich versenden
aber verliert gar nichts sagt eigentlich
alles so krass viele erzählen
ja ich habe sogar die es gibt
genau das schaffen dann schlafen gehen
und dann mache ich das sagt aber kurz zu
damit wie es hier mit einer schönen
natur zwischen schaden
ich denke und ich wollten eventuell auch
wenn wir heute noch dazu kommen unsere
grundstücke verbinden
ja ich habe eigentlich gedacht an so was
schön ist die norm ein kart strecke hat
die schule werde ich den sender erhält
also ich nehme ich nicht genehmen müssen
mit
von mir aus kann es machen da braucht
mir nur auf jeder seite man mein partner
ja wir könnten aber auch eine
automatische strecke machen sie sehe ich
auf einmal den regen war jetzt ein
direkter als regen aufgehört hat was mit
meinem bienchen ach so die fangen jetzt
an zu arbeiten ja sogar wie immer fiel
dort aus fliegen liegt meinem bildschirm
blickt ich muss vielleicht so lehwald
laufen bis ich wieder beim einen
komischen rawert ratings punkt bin ich
so was
ach so wenn du rupert riess und ganz
viel von gummi brauchst musst du einfach
ein extra extra kick back teuer kann man
das dreifache ja aber ich brauche
erstmal patrice und ich habe ja keiner
und ich die haben ja schon welche und
meine die ich gefunden habe die sind vor
des übels weit weg soll ich da war
settings schenken
das wird es nicht darauf bin ich in ost
stolpert ich habe leider kein adolf
krumpl war sie auch ein bisschen klingt
ja noch mal auf vier stück den rest
trägt kurz geschockt ich denke auch ganz
nebenbei das ist mittlerweile etabliert
dass ich auch immer wir wissen was
bringt dir nehmen weil bei mir genauso
sachen immer so sachen die ich neben mir
immer beim aufnehmen liegen habe einfach
eine flasche wasser mit mein handy
gerade hatte ich noch tee und einfach
eine packung taschentücher falls sich
zwischen die nase putzen muss aber das
hat das erledigt mein anwalt
mittlerweise sind total mrd
ich komm vorbei doch klappt hier haste
und da ganz ganz leicht wachsen lassen
dankeschön gerne gerne denn auch ein
dass verbraucher sind halt erstmal
wirklich etwas papier 7 fahren mich
jetzt aber ich denke so eine farm seiner
seite ach so etwas noch weiter sehen
wollte und zwar generell habe ich ja
schon der erzeugte strom aus
real wie zb kohle bedburg speichert die
energie wieder auch schon cool meint es
wird dir empfehlen ein geothermie
generate zu bauen
er braucht wirklich nicht der kostet
wirklich nicht viel mehr man muss
einfach einen generator erweitern
und dann musst kannst du auch ein lover
einmal antun dann vergaß nicht die ganze
kohle weil die leute später noch mal was
soll ich mit bauen geotherm geothermal
generator
ich habe mir ist aber schon normalen rad
gebaut jaja aber den schalter den doch
für alles was du brauchst